a black mother says her daughter was not
allowed to compete with her Colorado
cheerleading squad because of her hair
tiana young says her 11 year old
daughter Naima was kicked off the team
because the coach refused to let her
perform with her natural hair but the
cheerleading coach says yama was
dismissed because her mom threatened the
team vladimir duthiers our streaming
service cbsn is with us again how did
this begin sounds like a big he-said
she-said we said they said a little bit
of all of the above Gail so the coach
asked Naima to wear the hairpiece to fit
in with the rest of the team which she
says is mostly white and latina Tiana
Young says styling Imus naturally curly
hair for cheerleading can be painful for
her daughter
it is easily a two-hour process I have
to literally use a hard brush and pull
her hair back into the tightest ponytail
I can get it into Tiana Young says
diamond elite all-star cheerleading
coach and owner Stephanie Trujillo asked
her daughter to wear a ponytail hair
piece to match her teammates Nemea wore
it for a whole season but became
lightheaded at competitions because the
ponytail was too tight Trujillo made an
exception for Nemea
last season coach said well she doesn't
like it she's not to wear it but this
season Young says the coach had a change
of heart calling out new Maia at
practice coach continues and asked the
other team like how do you thought this
african-american girl gets to wear her
natural hair the national governing body
for us cheer and dance team says hair
must be secured off the face with a
simple and unexaggerated style that is
adaptable to all diversities but some
parents say young is overreacting this
kind of blindsided all of us I think
especially over something as my new as a
$10 ponytail Young says her daughter was
kicked off the team for true Hilo claims
it's because Young made threats against
the staff diamond elite cheerleading
says namaz dismissal was never based on
the athlete or her ethnic background the
decision was based on threats received
that were directed at the staff which
brought forth major safety concerns
Young says she never threatened anyone
I've worked hard to
to not become that person that
unfortunately black women and black men
are portrayed to be is violent whether
they're white black Asian curly hair
straight hair no hair all girls should
feel supported Diamond elite
cheerleading says it's reviewing uniform
guidelines and expectations for all
ethnic groups and accusations about
racism are untrue Young says Maya
doesn't even want to cheer anymore
because she doesn't feel welcome that
she does another cheer community that's
she just wants an apology that is a hot
mess there is a very sensitive issue for
little girls certainly little girls of
color I think they need to figure out a
way to let her wear her hair the way she
wants yeah the way she needs to wear her
hair but the thing with the mother and
their cheerleading that's that's another
that seems to me to be another story
telling Maya new losses out she's the
one yes now she doesn't want to cheer
yeah which that's a shame